on continue d'en parler avec nos invités
ils sont en direct avec nos cartons de
16 avocats au barreau de paris bruno
m'égare ban chefs de service réanimation
à l'hôpital lariboisière messieurs
bonjour bruno et garba nous connaissons
la situation des hôpitaux aux antilles
qu'elle est aujourd'hui celle des
hôpitaux en métropole et est ce que les
effets de la vaccination se font déjà
ressentir
écoutez les hôpitaux en métropole font
face à la quatrième vague hospitalière
donc aujourd'hui la pression sur les
services de réanimation et estimé de
l'ordre de 40% sur le territoire à
lariboisière par exemple le service que
je dirige 40% de nos lits sont occupés
par des patients ayant des formes graves
de lakovic 19 la caractéristique de ces
patients c'est que ils sont pour la
quasi-totalité non vaccinés donc de fait
effectivement on voit bien les effets de
la vaccination c'est à dire les
personnes qui sont vaccinées et bien ont
très peu de chances de se retrouver en
réanimation car ils ne développent pas
de forme grave
d'insuffisances respiratoires
liées à la copie de 19 qui les amène en
réanimation qui va faire qu'ils vont
passer plusieurs semaines à lutter pour
la vie il voir malheureusement un tiers
d'entre eux va mourir
carbon ne cesse vous êtes avocat le
conseil constitutionnel on le sait a
validé la majorité l'essentiel de la loi
sanitaire ça veut dire qu'ils estiment
que le pass and i ter est conforme à la
constitution
bonjour madame oui vous avez raison il
vient de clôturer le débat en validant
l'essentiel de la loi mais en des termes
qui sont assez sévères en rappelant qu'
il s'agit bien d'un état d'exception et
que celui ci doit être strictement
encadré dans le temps et qu'il ne valide
que parce que la loi a donné de date sur
eure de ne pas prolonger au delà de la
mi novembre
évidemment en l'état des connaissances
de développement de virus aujourd'hui le
conseil constitutionnel a statué donc
vous avez raison l'essentiel des
dispositions du pont de la loi a été
validée par le conseil constitutionnel
bon mes gars ben on a une question qui
revient souvent aussi le vaccin
n'empêche pas la contamination calé son
utilité vous êtes médecin chef d'un
service de ranimation vous allez donc
pouvoir vous répondre
alors effectivement vous avez raison le
vaccin n'empêche pas d'être contaminés
d'ailleurs il n'empêche pas à 100 % le
risque de développer la maladie par
contre il réduit le risque il s'inscrit
dans une stratégie de prévention c'est à
dire de réduction des risques on sait
aujourd'hui vous pouvez regarder les
chiffres fournis par santé publique
france
sur la base de données de kovy tracker
comme d'ailleurs sur le logiciel tout
senti qu vide et bien les personnes
vaccinées ont
une chance / 8 un risque / 8 d'être
contaminés de développer des signes de
la maladie et de se retrouver en
réanimation c'est donc un traitement
préventif extrêmement efficace voyez on
aurait huit fois moins de patients en
réanimation eh bien on n'en parlerait
pas du tout dans les médias aujourd'hui
ça serait parfaitement dans les
capacités de nos services de réanimation
et donc nous pourrions gérer ces
quelques cas sans aucun problème
l'installation dans la durée de ce pass
sanitaires et particulièrement au coeur
des débats le dispositif peut être
imposée par le gouvernement jusqu'au 15
novembre 2000 21 normalement car bond de
16 craignez-vous qu'il aille au delà
car monde et c'est peut-être un petit
problème de liaison vous m'entendez oui
je vous entends et vous m'interrogez sur
la prolongation au-delà du 15 novembre
exactement et je vous disais que le
professeur ben gardane a bien posé les
données du problème qu'est ce que le
conseil constitutionnel le gouvernement
le conseil d'état le parlement vont se
poser comme question ils vont se poser
la question de l'est ques tion entre le
risque sanitaire est le risque de
prendre des dispositions contraires aux
libertés fondamentales et ils vont
devoir opérer ce difficiles arbitrages
maintenant que la jurisprudence est
établi pour dire qu'on peut admettre
pour une durée très courte
des exceptions aux principes
fondamentaux qui il devait y avoir à
nouveau un nouveau variant ou une
prolongation du risque épidémique à la
mi novembre
évidemment le gouvernement seraient
tentés de prolonger le pass sanitaires
et à ce moment là le parlement aurait à
se prononcer sur le fait de savoir si
cette cette prolongation est
disproportionnée au regard des atteintes
aux libertés fondamentales et le conseil
d'état et le conseil constitutionnel
également hors et a validé ou non cette
prolongation mon home & garden son
résultat probant de la mise en oeuvre de
se passer ni tard je veux dire si la
couverture vaccinale un souhaité par le
gouvernement n'est pas atteinte pensez
vous que la vaccination obligatoire pour
tous soit nécessaire
alors déjà on peut ressentir les
premiers effets positifs de ce pass
annie terre
depuis le discours du président environ
10 millions de personnes se sont
précipitées vers les centres de
vaccination pour être vacciné d'ailleurs
la france est désormais dans en tête
dans le temps dans les pays en tête en
europe du nombre de primo vacciner même
si il est encore devancé par le royaume
uni en termes de vaccination complète
donc c'est déjà en fait un succès même
si je suis d'accord avec avec vous
beaucoup de ces personnes qui se sont
précipités pour se faire vacciner ça
n'est pas par conviction de l'intérêt de
la vaccination mais plutôt pour pouvoir
rpt fréquenté la salle de sport
retourner dans les salles de théâtre ou
de cinéma tout simplement partir en
vacances et pouvoir aller en boîte de
nuit quel que soit l'objectif de but à
nouveau en termes de santé publique
c'est de pousser le plus grand nombre à
se faire vacciner le plus rapidement
possible car à nouveau ce qui est en jeu
ce n'est pas tellement la situation
d'aujourd'hui est déjà relativement
sérieuse c'est la situation qui va
arriver en septembre octobre car nous
allons faire face à une réelle
augmentation des contaminations
avec la reprise de la vie sociale et
économique en septembre avec le
refroidissement des températures avec la
réouverture des écoles et universités
les contaminations vont augmenter car le
virus va circuler notamment parmi les
adolescents et les enfants et de fait il
faudrait totalement dissociées la
circulation du virus de l'augmentation
des patients qui vont venir à l'hôpital
car malheureusement si à nouveau cet
hiver nous devons prendre en charge un
nombre très important de patients et
lakovic 19 l'hôpital public va couler il
faut savoir évidemment qu'il est déjà
avant même le début de l'automne à
moitié plein par des patients et à la
copie de 19 on n'a pas de capacité
renoue permettant de faire face à une
crise aussi grave que les vagues
précédentes et de plus comme vous le
savez malheureusement un certain nombre
de soignants ont quitté l'hôpital et
donc de fait évidemment nous sommes en
situation de faiblesse on risquerait de
se retrouver dans une situation aussi
grave qu aux antilles
cinquième samedi de mobilisation du
monde manifestement travers toute la
france carbon de 16 quel regard portez
vous sur ce mouvement de contestation
qui manifestement prendre le car
oui il prend de l'ampleur à la mi août
c'est à dire au moment où il devrait
être au contraire le moins vif je pense
qu'il ya là une question fondamentale et
pour revenir sur
l'intervention précédente du professeur
m'égare ban il ya beaucoup de gens qui
donc se font vacciner parce qu'ils ont
peur de ne pas pouvoir exercer des
libertés fondamentales dont une qu'il a
commise c'est celle de travailler et par
conséquent quand on renvoie simplement
aux activités de loisirs ou aux
activités culturelles on minore la
crainte qu'ont eu beaucoup de gens qui
ont été se faire vacciner en réalité
sous contrainte parce que si la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire des
youyous réel et defacto et si vous vous
laissez s'alimente débat que pose
cette vaccination est ce pas de
sanitaires et de savoir si dans nos
traditions juridiques et citoyenne il
est préférable de convaincre ou de
contraindre
messieurs merci d'avoir été avec nous on
dirait que sur rt france car bond de 16
est avocat au barreau de paris avec nous
également bruno un megaman chefs de
service réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris merci à vous de
messiaen